So,
same thing here,
they're selling,
you know,
ha,
he's the great father of the family and
these,
these kids are,
they're kind of like the Soviet
equivalent of cub scouts.
They're sort of worship a game.
And then I really liked the other one on
the,
on the right,
because I mean,
you could hardly find a more hellish
representation of a tyrant than that.
Right?
I mean,
it looks,
and this is quite interesting,
it looks like Stellan is standing in
front of a man.
Door lock is Amanda Orla is a shape like
this and all shape.
You see that in renaissance art all the
time.
It's an extremely old symbol.
It's the oldest symbol that people have
ever found evidence for.
And the thing is on fire.
It's like Stella,
there he is,
King of Hell.
And it's exactly right.
You know,
it's,
it's eerie that that's the mode of
representation that emerged for them,
but it's certainly accurate.
So,
you know,
the whole tyrannical end of the great
father is,
this is the sort of thing that results
from it,
you know,
it's like the,
the,
uh,
elevation of the person at the top of
the dominance hierarchy to the status of
some kind of quasi identity certainly
happened in Hitler's case.
And then the brutal murderousness that
can emerge from that,
those are pictures from the
concentration camps at the end of World
War Two.
So,
you know,
so I told you that the feminine can be
rep that terrible unknown things can be
represented by the feminine,
sort of a monstrous figure,
you know,
but it's certainly the case that the
monstrosity of culture is roughly
equivalent to the monstrosity of nature.
You know,
and one of the things you might think
about is that common India tend to
utilize these symbolic categories.
It's almost as if they appropriate them.
So the environmental movement,
for example,
basically says benevolent nature,
right?
So that's the positive feminine negative
culture because that's cultures out
there,
rapaciously destroying the pristine
wilderness of Mother Nature and the
negative individual too.
Because you know,
human beings are part of that as
individuals and we're kind of a cancer
on the face of the planet,
if you know,
I mean that's pretty dark way of looking
at it obviously,
but it's one sided because you could
easily say,
yeah,
well,
you know,
we're in a war with nature because
obviously she's trying to kill us as
fast as possible and we better have some
culture because otherwise we'd be
sitting outside in the freezing snow and
you know,
you might be a re patients consumer,
but on the other hand you're just trying
to survive and it's not that easy.
And so,
you know,
you need to have both of those stories
together before you have a reasonable
representation of the world.
It's not easy to cope with something
like,
well like that.
It's not easy to cope with something
like that in every institution has this
potential and this element because
institutions tend towards
bureaucratization and tyranny as they
develop.
They close up and become rigid.
And so,
you know,
that's a rough thing to deal with.
And then of course is a rough thing to
deal with too.
So you might think,
well,
you could have a little bit of sympathy
for human beings,
not just throw them in the horrible
rapacious creature category,
which I think is an extraordinarily
pathological and also a pre genocidal
thing to do,
you know,
because you hear environment to lists
for example now,
and then say the planet would be better
off without people on.
It's like,
well,
you know,
that's Kinda what Hitler thought as well
about certain kinds of people anyways.
And God only knows where he would have
stopped.
So you know,
when someone says something like that,
one of the things you might think is you
should take a good look at your
unconscious structure there Bucko,
because fundamentally you're,
you know,
there is a genocidal ideology at the
bottom of your thoughts structure.
And you know,
you might think that you're an
environmentalist but you're actually
possessed by a genocidal etiology and
you better do something about that.
Because if you ever get any power,
you're going to be one dangerous
creature.